Which would be more helpful for use on a person with a hairline fracture in the knee?
A true rife with a crystal hammer bulb alone or
Connected to the jackhammer amplifier
What's your opinion of the jack hammer amplifier?
And then the next part of the question would it be more beneficial to purchase the overnight tornado bulb and use that?
This would be for daytime use
So
First of all, we're making the assumption that the rife machine is going to be super helpful on a hairline hairline fracture of the knee
I'm not saying that it can't be I'm just not saying that
It necessarily would be so if I had to again, I've said this time of time again
But these are tools all we have is tools. So the rife machine is a tool. There's a lot of other therapy tools
So if I had a hairline fracture of the knee out of all the therapy tools that exist
That I may have access to
What one would I use? Well, if I had a hairline fracture of the knee, I would use laser that would be my choice
If I had a
Sprayed like a really bad ankle spray. I would use laser if I had a muscle contusion a muscle pull like it pulled a muscle
You know doing pickle more or something like that. What would I use? I would use electrical stem like a tens unit or a EMS unit
Some sort of electrical stem Russian stem something like that
If I had a
Frozen shoulder with
calcific
Tendonitis or something like that. I would use ultrasound laser could be helpful for that
The rife could be helpful for all of these you have a rife at home
So I understand the question. I already have a rife at home. I don't have a laser at home. I don't have a PEF at home
I don't have a hyperbaric at home. I don't have an electrical stem machine at home. I don't certainly don't have
Laser or an ultrasound at home
But you may go to a carpenter or you know a therapist physical therapist that has those things
and if if I had a hairline fracture the
laser would be
Would be far superior I think but you have a true rife so you could do it daily
So what would you use with the crystal hammer bulb load be enough?
Yes, I think so. Do I need the jackhammer amplifier now the true rife has a possible jack high-ever amplifier
Well for those who listen to me very much. I'm not a big fan of the jackhammer amplifier anyhow
So I would say no you don't need the jackhammer you're only going you're at your knee the hairline fracture of your knee
um, I don't know if it's your knee cap the patella or if it's the
It's more likely the base of the tibia
uh
It's uh
You know your your crystal hammer bulb is going to be plenty enough to penetrate that you don't need the jackhammer
There's absolutely no need for that. Do you need to add the overnight tornado bulb?
Would that be better? No, no, it wouldn't you again you just need the frequencies to penetrate
um, so no the crystal hammer bulb
Is plenty adequate to do that. There's no need to add anything else
But again, these are tools again the to rife to me for a fracture would not be the number one tool. I would use
uh, it would you know again the rife machine is going to be better to kill cancer to kill pathogens
Um, yes, it could help heal organs and bring organs back to
It's normal frequency synergy like heat helping you heal the liver helping you heal
Which in a sense is going to help you with detoxification. Is it going to help you heal
soft tissue
bone or muscle?
Yes, it can. I tell my story of it healing my frozen shoulder
But uh, I tell you I've done I've had people use the rife on musculoskeletal things
You know, based upon my story of it healing my frozen shoulder and and I've used it on other musculoskeletal things
With cvledo real help
so I would just um
You know, I would use it because I have it
But I would think about using other therapies
That maybe better tools in that instance